we need to have a serious conversation
here at the top of the show and you know
I get emails people saying Oh David your
Schilling for Hillary how much is the
Hillary campaign paying you nonsense
like this obviously that's ridiculous
I've been super clear I supported Bernie
Sanders in the Democratic primary right
now Hillary Clinton is the best choice
we need to keep Donald Trump out of the
White House but there's clearly some
kind of major misunderstanding that's
going on between me and you in the
audience at least with some people in
the audience and we need to clear it up
right now but really go further and talk
pragmatically about what the next four
years could be depending on who wins on
november eighth and what made me think
of this is you know that the uracil
emails i I can sort of easily disregard
it's mostly hatreds but last week there
were reasonable live calls and
reasonable viewer email saying David
what do you like so much about Hillary
Clinton what good things will Hillary
Clinton do if she becomes the next
president let me be incredibly clear
right now Hillary Clinton winning on
november eighth is not the victory
hillary clinton winning on november
eighth is the minimum that we need to
prevent worldwide embarrassment and the
disaster of a clueless serial sex abuser
vulture capitalist from being given the
keys to the country okay if Hillary
Clinton wins that's when the real work
starts because it will be a rare
opportunity getting a corporatist
Democrat in office is not a progressive
victory right but having twelve
consecutive years of predictable
moderate centre-left Democrats in the
White House is an opportunity because if
Hillary Clinton wins that will be the
first period of 12 consecutive years of
Democrats in the White House since
Franklin Delano Roosevelt and Harry
Truman served consecutively from
nineteen thirty three to nineteen
forty-five
you have to go back not that much less
than a hundred years to when we had more
than eight years of a Democratic
president if we can defeat Donald Trump
we haven't won yet we've simply said now
the work can actually start for
progressives and I hope you're ready for
it because Hillary Clinton will be
completely predictable Pat in what she
will do right ostensibly progressive on
social issues moderate on economic
issues with likely some things that we
would think of as positive neoliberal on
foreign policy on November ninth if
Hillary Clinton wins I don't know what
other programs are going to be doing
right Pat it'll probably be the launch
point for Trump TV as we've talked about
but on this program I will celebrate
that we finally have a woman president
it's about time but I'm gonna be ready
to get to work because that's the
opportunity not the victory and there's
even some arguments being made by some
progressives that a trump victory would
actually be better for us because it
would cause this sort of like liberal
resurgence II for the midterms in for
2020 I don't think that's the best way
to go at all but but I think there's
some legitimacy there I think the best
way is to just keep the pressure on her
Andy maybe even primary her if need be I
have no question that this let it all
burn down mentality of a trump
presidency will embolden progresses you
know it may be true to some extent but
the Supreme Court three supreme court
justices selected by Donald Trump I
still don't think progressives are
understanding what that would mean we're
going to talk about the real way that
the erection election is is oh I all
said the wrong thing there wow that dog
about a Freudian slip the real way that
the election is rigged uh has everything
to do with gerrymandering and the
Supreme Court is related to that
corporate media is not going to be part
of pushing for progressive change on
november nine i'm ready to go to work if
Hillary Clinton wins if Donald Trump
wins on november eighth good luck to the
US and we'll be here playing defense and
trying to stop the insanity but there
will be no real opportunity if Hillary
Clinton wins
it's time to activate it will be the
biggest opportunity in nearly 100 years
to move the country significant to the
significantly to the left and the
circumstances are ripe for change the
country has moved left on many issues if
you look at the electorate as left as
ever on abortion as left as ever on LGBT
rights as left is ever on the problem of
income inequality in the way in which
corporations have this Oleg article
stranglehold on the country we'll talk
about that later AT&T buying CNN and a
third Democratic presidential term will
actually be the possibility of making
progressive change to our country right
the electorate has moved left but by and
large our politicians have not we will
need independent media to achieve
anything and don't think I'm here
cheerleading Hillary Clinton because by
elected her things are just going to
instantly get better right Donald Trump
suggested this ludicrous notion in the
third and final debate where if I get to
be President and select Supreme Court
justices automatically roe v wade will
be overturned things don't happen
automatically that wouldn't happen
automatically if Donald Trump gets his
way and Hillary Clinton winning won't
automatically make this country more
progressive it's just going to open the
door I'll be working towards it and
hopefully you understand that now in the
short term in the in the two weeks and a
day that we have left until this
election we need to keep Donald Trump
out we need to vote in the down ballot
races particularly House and Senate
because that will be a major factor in
what can be achieved don't email me
saying David explain to me why you're so
thrilled about the possibility of a
Hillary Clinton when it has nothing to
do with Hillary Clinton's politics
individually it has everything to do
with the fact that if progressives are
ready on november nine they're really in
the third week of january when hillary
clinton will be elected uh we've got to
go to work and it will be time to
actually say this is an opportunity
we've not had for nearly 100
years let's now critique the left from
the left